c'est une visite historique pour le
maroc deux jours au sein du royaume
chérifien pour yaïr lapid ministre
israélien des affaires étrangères il
s'agit d'une sorte de concrétisation de
la normalisation des relations entre
rabat et tel aviv au programme de cette
visite une rencontre avec son homologue
nasser bourita l'ouverture d'une
représentation diplomatique dans la
capitale marocaine et la signature de
trois accords de coopération dont un en
matière de cyberdéfense c'est une
première visite officielle qui
intervient quelques semaines après
l'ouverture des vols commerciaux directs
entre les deux pays une venue loin de
faire l'unanimité dans le monde arabe
notamment en cisjordanie et à gaza où le
rapprochement entre les deux états et
d'yves mans critiqué les responsables
palestiniens évoquent même une trahison
alors que le roi du maroc lui temps de
prouver le contraire - métis avait
notamment promis au président mahmoud
abbas la poursuite de l'engagement
permanent et soutenue du maroc en faveur
de la cause palestinienne juste après
les émirats arabes unis le bahreïn et le
soudan le maroc est le quatrième pays
arabes à avoir normalisé ses relations
avec israël en 2020 sous l'impulsion des
etats-unis de donald trump en
contrepartie d'une reconnaissance
américaine de sa souveraineté sur le
territoire disputé du sahara occidental